bonsoir les humains
ça va Jean-Mi tu as eu de bons échos de
ta prestation de la semaine dernière oui
super on a même proposé la météo du
Grand Journal
pose ta question mon petit vous n'auriez
pas des adresses à me conseiller pour
des vacances en Tunisie
il y en a des tas d'adresses superbes la
Tunisie est un pays superbe elle est
tunisien sont des gens extrêmement
tolérants et formidables voilà Jean-Mi
c'est Thierry qui m'a obligé à poser
cette question
je prendrai ta place il y a une question
que jamais personne vous a posé c'était
bien ces fameuses vacances en Tunisie
qui vous ont obligé à démissionner elles
ont toujours été formidables je suis
allé pendant 6 ou 7 ans quand même
Michel a lieu Maryse qui est bizarre
c'est que vous voyez arriver là la
tentation totalitaire de la bouche j'ai
pas vu arriver la tentation de totalité
de Ben Ali à l'époque
écoutez on pourrait en parler mais c'est
pas ici où ça doit se faire ce qui lui
était reproché d'ailleurs c'était
beaucoup plus les malversations de la
famille de sa femme que qu'autre chose
comme vous discutez avec les Tunisiens
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu